okay I've been waiting we've had to keep
putting this off but I finally do want
to get to it today we surveyed our
audience over a couple of week period of
not long ago and we have what I feel is
a pretty good representative sample of
the audience about 12 or 1300 audience
members filled out the survey and it
asked any number of compelling questions
about what you like about the show what
you would like to see in the future
about the show and I want to go over
some of the results if you'll allow me
Pat I hope that this will be at this
will this will please the production
team I think it's okay you think it's
okay alright so let's dig into it some
of the revelations from the from the
survey I would like more of the
following topics on the show
overwhelmingly world politics is
something that scored very highly as
people wanting more of it on the show
followed by more US politics which is
sort of like the main thing we do as
well as technology and science stories a
lot of people wanting more technology
and science stories that's interesting
and that's something we can absolutely
do although what's interesting is
although technology stories scored very
high highly here the technology stories
we do don't often do that well
interesting I mean these are the people
filling out the survey that are very
involved in the show itself is
electrically the people who would
definitely check out those clips I think
yeah no doubt about it okay also from
the survey results I would like less of
the following topics on the show
overwhelmingly sports followed by
entertainment and food diet lifestyle
stories surprise Pat about the sports
thing I mean we really only cover sports
when there other than just talking about
Boston sports teams when there's like a
big game going on briefly we don't talk
about much we really do sports stories
that have a political angle to them are
you surprised that sports was
overwhelmingly what people want less of
on the show yeah because we so rarely do
that and like you said I remember we
covered a patriot story when it came out
that Bill Belichick and Tom Brady might
be supporting Donald Trump but that's
more of a political story at heart yes
it is absolutely ok let's continue also
from our survey as far a little bit cut
off there but I'll tell you what's going
on here as far as voices this is my
fault i created these pictures
as far as voices on the show do you
prefer the most common response more
David talking and less of other people
forty-six percent want for forty six
percent want more of me talking unless
of other people nineteen percent want
more of other people talking than me and
thirty-five percent responded with other
maybe that means it's fine the way it is
I don't know yeah yeah alright let's
continue on our survey results here
which is your favorite recurring segment
segment on the show overwhelmingly
patriot mail and live phone calls
together making up nearly sixty percent
of viewers favorite recurring segments
on the show that's interesting live
phone calls is interesting because the
calls do well but i also get complaints
from people saying they don't like the
friday life live phone calls so it seems
if you like it you like it a lot but you
also might hate it not many people
feeling the amazon segments now people
know that that's tiny tiny little uh
that's not even really a segment
arguably i mean we're just kind of
talking about hey you can support us
through amazon but that is interesting
okay next what else do we have here when
i hear from co host and producer vote
voices the most interesting thing is
when they overwhelmingly seventy-four
percent say present a different or
original idea to David so I thought that
disagree with David would be way better
way WAY stronger of a response only
eight percent say that they like it when
other voices disagree with me
overwhelmingly people want alternative
ideas presented well the thing is you
can present an alternative idea while at
the same time agreeing or disagreeing
and then often what I tried to do yes
there you go alright is that it yes okay
so some of the results from the survey
very very interesting thanks to the
twelve or thirteen hundred people also
in the comments section overwhelmingly
when people could write something in
longer interviews with one of the most
common things and we've taken that to
heart and have started doing some
two-part interviews so each show is
still only one quarter interview but the
interviews in total are longer and
people seem to be liking that